all right you squeezed in your first
grievance last segment by saying don't
go deep into the playbook when the
starter at quarterback is injured give
the starter that menu of plays right
because it'll help him with the offense
here's mine in honor of the trade
deadline coming and going yesterday the
tuesday after week eight it used to be
the tuesday after week six now that
we've got seven teams that will make the
playoffs in each conference they need to
move it back some more because it's too
early for teams to fold the tents and
sell off assets and build for the future
and make an arms length negotiation
transaction with another team it's got
to go to the tuesday after week 10 at
the absolute earliest look i'm a firm
believer in total and free market
transactions where you make trades
anytime you want now i'd say that the
rosters should lock of the non-playoff
teams once the regular season ends so
you can't have non-playoff teams selling
off assets and
resurrecting the seasons of players who
would then jump on board a playoff
franchise but but chris i just i don't
like the trade deadline generally and i
don't like it tuesday after week eight
if we're going to have 14 teams in the
playoffs mike it's uh i never thought of
that but i i think you're right i mean i
i think that that does kind of make the
perfect point yeah it's seven teams
right now you look at the playoffs
there's very few teams that you can look
at and go it's over
new england doesn't think it's over
they're two and five they're only two
games back so you're right they're not
going to fold the tents you know there's
a lot of other teams same thing in the
nfc you know of course yeah there's the
teams down there same thing all the
teams that are two and five are only two
games back and some of those teams that
are are in the playoffs on the bottom
they got some tough games coming so i i
think you're spot on i think i think
it's got to be somewhere around week 10
11
to be realistic to finally to where you
get another handful of teams to go we're
out of this we got to start thinking
about next year let's make moves
whatever and then you have other teams
who let's say if you're not you know
you've just gotten healthy right now and
now you start to go on a run and also
you go wait we are the team we thought
we were you know before the injuries
oh man i wish we could make a move now
because we're we are a super bowl or a
deep in the playoffs type team um so i'm
with you you know that's that's a pretty
damn good idea uh do you want me to go
with my next grievance go ahead
you know it a little already but it just
i talked about it a little yesterday or
monday whatever day that was but you
know the current stance of the nfl with
the quarterback getting hit and sliding
and everything like that has got to
change you know the defense has already
been screwed over they can't do anything
anymore they're not allowed to play the
ball i mean they're not allowed to hit
anybody going over the middle even when
they hit him the correct way it still
gets flagged you know now we got
quarterbacks coming into football every
year that can run and make plays they're
not all lamar jackson i get that but we
see justin herbert and joe burrow
they're running around everywhere they
can do things like that
russell wilson this week was going to
slide and the defense stopped and he ran
a few more yards when they're running
out the clock and got them into a
third and one or fourth and one
situation i can't remember exactly but
then so he fakes the slide and then runs
a little more and then tries to slide
and gets hit in the head and they call a
penalty what is the defender supposed to
do and then it's lamar jackson on the
edge of the the defense
he's as explosive as anybody in the
league he's been hit on the sideline
he's not out of bounds he's a good foot
and a half inbounds both feet he gets
his clock cleaned by cam hayward what
he's supposed to do
you can't over protect these
quarterbacks this way that's not fair
you're ruining football to me for me i
don't want to see
that type of free yardage given away in
a physical sport where we're seeing
quarterbacks having to run more and more
and more and more the days of brady and
breeze and the pocket passer it's
limited they're they're going out of the
league it's out of style and i think the
nfl really has to look at that hard
yeah look the protections evaporate the
moment the quarterback decides to become
a runner and the quarterbacks are taking
advantage of those protections whether
it's the matt ryan okeydoke at the
sideline that was from yeah one of last
season where he like slows down and the
defense slows down he says fine i'm
going to take 10 more yards or or
whether it's lamar jackson flopping and
admitting through the microphone that he
had on at the time that he flopped and
it worked yeah it it the balance
is out of whack and uh the nfl needs to
do something about it the problem is i
think the officials are so conditioned
yeah they take the quarterbacks it's
going to take some time it's going to
take some
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports